hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
Martin Heidegger begins being in time by
stressing the need to recover a question
that of being which turns out to be the
question of the meaning of being now
that sounds very very abstract very
metaphysical and you may be wondering
what he's talking about there what
exactly is the being and and how do we
formulate this question
Heidegger works at that precisely by
pointing out to us that there's a good
reason why this should appear puzzling
why it may not even seem like a real
object of inquiry or a starting point he
tells us that this is the very beginning
line this question has today been
forgotten and why is it been forgotten
he thinks that this has to do with an
entire line of philosophical approaches
that begin with the ancient Greeks with
Plato Aristotle come all the way down to
you know such luminaries such as Hegel
with his science of logic which
Heidegger references there and
everything in between and beyond that is
involved with this particular attitude
towards being that comes from as
Heidegger would say an inadequate
ontology so he tells us that there's a
dogma in place already what is a dogma
when we talk about somebody being
dogmatic we mean that they have some
sort of preconceived notion or belief
that they are relying upon now there's
an older conception of dogma that says
that it's it's something that you need
to believe in order to make any sort of
progress and Heidegger here wants to
question something that has been framed
as a dogma if we're going to do
philosophy or indeed if we're going to
do any sort of discipline or inquiry at
all
this has to do with with being itself so
he tells us what is this Dogma that
being is the most universal and empty of
concepts he's going to go on and tell us
that this resists every attempt at
definition this most universal and thus
indefinable concept doesn't need any
definition everybody uses it constantly
already understand what's meant by it by
it and he tells us this is what troubled
or thus what troubled ancient
philosophizing and kept it so by virtue
of its obscurity has become to us in the
present obvious clear as day
and if you begin asking about being
people will say oh you're making a big
dinners mistake Heidegger wants to take
us back beyond that and he talks about
three prejudices he identifies three
particular ways in which people are
setting a stumbling block in in the way
of even conceiving that there could be a
question of being so the first prejudice
is that being is the most universal
concept and I highlight that term
Universal there because Heidegger is
going to stress to us that there's more
than one way of being universal he
quotes a few nice passages from Greek
and Latin you know to Olin SDK the
lumati stop Hanten allude called primo
cottage some apprehension a test n
squeeze intellectus included to an
omnibus cweickum quick quiz apprehended
and then summarizes these by saying an
understanding of being has already
contained in everything we apprehend in
beings
now if being is a universal concept what
does that mean for us to be universal
let's think by way of analogy to these
pieces of chalk right three individual
pieces is there some sort of universal
that encompasses them yes chalk and you
know we could say writing implement or
we could say hard substance mineral or
something along those lines and what
we're doing there is we're moving from a
lower level of individuality and
specificity up to higher and higher
levels of what we might nowadays call
classes or types but in ancient
philosophy these were called species and
then genus now is being a genus some
people have treated it as if it is such
Heidegger says no being is not a genus
and as a matter of fact Aristotle knew
this already so it doesn't have the kind
of universality that genus does he says
being does not delimit the highest
region of beings in so far as they are
conceptually articulated according
according to genus and species so if we
want to say that being is in fact the
most universal it's not Universal in the
way that we're most often considering
universality so we want to put this
prejudice aside the second prejudice
that he discusses is that the concept of
being is indefinable now think about how
we define things now go beyond just
providing a verbal definition or you
know let alone some sort of tendentious
stipulative definition that happens to
you know fit whatever you're trying to
do at a particular time think about what
it means when we really do
in fact define something we say what it
is we provide a verbal formula that in
some respect is is supposed to capture
the essence of whatever the thing is why
wouldn't we be able to define being he
says this conclusion is drawn from its
highest universality and correctly so if
definition happens through the proc
Magina sand specific difference if if we
define by saying first what kind of
thing it is and then saying how it's
different from other things and we can't
do that with being now can we but again
we need to think is this the only way to
define things are we relying on a
prejudice here then the third thing he
comes to the third prejudice being is
the most self-evident concept once again
we have to think about this term what
does self-evident mean and this has a
long historical you know set of
connotations within philosophy
something is self-evident if you don't
need to explain it if as soon as
somebody runs into it they immediately
grasp it or understand what's going on
with it and he says being is used in all
knowing and predicating and every
relation of beings and in every relation
to oneself and the expression is
understandable without further ado
everyone understands for examples he
provides the sky is blue there is there
is the being right I am happy and
similar statements and he says but this
average comprehensibility only
demonstrates the incomprehensible 'ti it
shows that an enigma lies in any use of
being in relations in predication and
you name it there's a kind of enigma
there and many of the treatments of
being have said there's no question here
it being just is what it is and that
that's it we can talk about all the
other things but we can't effectively
talk about being because you're already
presuming it just a time just to talk
about it here so Heidegger says no we we
actually do need to ask this question
what is the meaning
of being is it possible for us to
actually conceptualize being already in
asking that question we're making in
advance beyond these prejudices beyond
this dogma he tells us that the question
the question itself of the meaning of
being must be formulated and he says
this this has to be brought to a
suitable transparency so he says well
let's think for a minute what it means
to actually question not just ask a
single question but to question to
inquire after things questioning he says
is a kind of seeking now this may seem
perfectly obvious to you but think about
how seeking works
you've lost your car keys do you just go
looking everywhere for them or are you
guided by something is there anything
that tells you well maybe don't look in
your car itself right unless you're
prone to leaving your car keys in your
car in which case something else guides
you to that so he says every seeking
takes a direction beforehand from what
is sought it's not a pure random
exercise so he says questioning is a
knowing search for beings in there that
nisonger gives a whole bunch of examples
of you know different types of
questioning and then he says okay let's
come back to the point the question to
be formulated is about the meaning of
being so we have to exploit eight the
question of being with regard to its
structural moments so he says
questioning needs prior guidance from
what it seeks in this way we have to be
getting prior guidance from being now we
already as we know were you know this is
this whole idea of it being self-evident
relied on the fact that we already
comport ourselves in relation to being
we already are involved with being we
just don't quite know
being is at the point that we begin
inquiring about it but we can take a
sort of direction from that so he says
we can what is asked about in the
question it to be elaborated in is being
that which determines beings as beings
that in terms which of which beings have
always been understood no matter how
they are discussed now he tells us
something else important here the being
of beings is not itself a being let me
say that one more time because it may be
you know a little bit difficult to wrap
your head around the being of beings
whole plenitude of beings is not itself
a being it's not one thing that we can
point towards so already we're getting
some slight clarification about the
question of being now perhaps this may
not have illuminated everything but you
have at least a puzzle in front of you
and if that's the case then you do
understand something that there is
indeed a question of being to ask and
then pursue
you